the dark side no no go yeah that's my
emperor quote right there okay guys
we're gonna watch the Star Wars Rises
Skywalker kylo Ren meets the emperor
movie clip put up our reaction to the
featurettes that came out then to
discover oh there was a clip that
dropped I'm like do I really want to
watch this clip but I just finished
watching Return of the Jedi this week
and I was like yeah I'm in the mood to
see some Palpatine stuff first and let's
see what's going on here and we actually
just require our reaction to the latest
episode the Mandalorian so keep a
lookout for that should be up tomorrow
morning anywho let's swing in action
here people very cool
Wow
ominous music
Wow
[Music]
has been inside
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
I've been every voice you've heard
inside your head so anytime he thought
he was talking to Vader no no I'm just
starting to feel bad for the Emperor ha
ha totally deserve some sympathy like he
has been working harder than most people
in the galaxy okay yeah I'm watching the
movies in timeline order and like I said
I just finished Return of the Jedi this
week and in Episode three he's like oh I
found my apprentice yes Anakin Skywalker
you know and then that went to shed and
then when Luke Skywalker's started
coming to the rise the rise of Skywalker
and he started coming into play they
were like we can use him yes this would
be good he was trying to manipulate
whoever's in the sky Walker clan and
then the next in line who's a Jedi into
becoming the darkside he succeeded with
Anakin but that went to [ __ ] obviously
and then Luke he tried that failed but
now he's like kylo Ren and now he's like
oh yes this is the one this is the one
we go this is the right one right here
he's definitely bad it's like poor dude
and then Ray's gonna show up and kill ya
and that blue that dark is blue
lightsaber moment force will be with you
boys
I just gonna do exactly what he did the
snow quit to the Empire I wonder though
if we'll get you know that Anakin
Skywalker force ghost cameo that people
haven't want people wanting like Hayden
Christensen to show which never
surprises me considering oh not well
receiving which I you know watching the
movies in timeline order especially that
time I got to Revenge of this if that
was like kind of reminds me as at times
of Mark Hamill a little bit so I don't
think all the discrediting goes to
Hayden Christensen on the performances
there because most great actors and
those articles were not who could agree
it was pretty good but anyway not in my
tankers incident our revenge of the city
but then you know hearing Palpatine
saying like everything you've been
seeing has just been me like in force
awakens when he's talking to the Darth
Vader helmets a truly good that must
have been Palpatine um I'm assuming and
then no no it's no steal it was just a
force projection of the emperor to keep
kylo under his thumb yeah he was the
some other Skywalker person maybes a
test is someone else yeah I did like the
mood of this I did like the tone they
call us a clip I don't imagine it moved
like this fast with his narration going
over it it did play more like a tease
for a scene as opposed to an actual clip
but felt like it sizzle reel for that
scene yeah it goes without saying like I
love the mood I love the music here yeah
I love the visuals they had to back it
up with I'm excited for the film man
we're gonna watch in just a few days and
I mean I'm excited to see what they got
in store and now I the thing I'm most
looking forward to because this is the
Skywalker saga so as much as Rey is the
main character I'm most looking forward
to seeing what happens with kylo Ren cuz
that's really the last thing to tie up
right yeah yeah last Skywalker if she is
so you know way yeah yeah it's funny
yeah we're gonna tie up the saga from
the dark side
put it all to rest I was watch this
season finale
which will do it better
remains to be seen but yeah I love the
setting too just like how cavern it
almost reminded me of Laura that rings
in a weird way like a like one of the
mines of moria or something about how
the damn bridge is like hiding out in
this most desolate yeah dark cavernous
horrible looking dank space like these
giant statues that they see flashes up
to that I'm sure people who have a
better grasp on the star wars complete
lore will know better you don't know who
they are
yeah in the brief little 0.5 second that
you saw there's a pamphlet in the back
of one of the novel this play is
explicitly I'd find it pretty
interesting if because in the firt and
the original trilogy Empire is generally
held to be the favorite and then in the
prequels the third one is considered to
be the favorite and if this one
completely sucks force awakens every
yeah it's interesting to see what the
ranking of each individual treasures you
know what I want to do I want to do a
Star Wars marathon where I watch all the
part ones then all the part twos then
all the part three anyway guys keep a
look out for our review for rise of
Skywalker we will do a spoiler talk as
well anyway guys what you think of this
clip you excited for Palpatine a guy
predictions comment below you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Abela get notified whenever
we got a youtube video up and before we
run through up i like to end this with a
page from the de shout out to a man
named Bailey Reichert Bailey is a fairly
new patron eject gave him a shout out
last month hails from Texas huge
wrestling fan usually takes about a week
or two to reply back to me and a week
ago I asked him how old are you by the
way and he responded 89 years old he is
our oldest
patron eject ever oldest person I know
to ever be into wrestling oh yeah he
gets in the ring sometimes to Bailey I
think it's 13
you're supposed to be to have a youtube
account Coppa family-friendly but not
that family-friendly he's our youngest
patron oh yeah yeah he swipe beat until
the sole story bike took his mom's
credit cards so he could help support
the channel and yeah so you know more
wrestling videos and stuff like that is
what he wanted I got the wrong tier you
know so maybe learn a little bit more
about math I know you just cut you some
slack you're a child but uh I wonder why
we're confused I don't know I don't know
oh it's because he hasn't replied back
to me so we can give him a more
personalized shout-out now that that
makes sense
Bailey don't you know that when you show
your support and contribution I demand
instantaneous responses yeah yeah man
now we have to just assume that you're
the average of eighty nine and thirteen
which makes you in white like your
mid-40s 51 the average of eighty nine
and thirteen 51
[Music]
because then I have this fear that by
the time next month rolls around you're
gonna unpledged you like didn't like my
shout out nice totally guess my age
wrong hope the shoutouts Maggie you
fueled each take your time man it's the
holidays I'm sure you're spending time
with your family and doing some Texas
things yeehaw
long girls raising some cattle drinking
a beer unattractive doing a lasso with a
10-gallon hat on here's a text we host
all right bud
you